what happens to them now good question i
guess you just keep them put them on
your shelf
no oh no no
oh my god oh my god
oh my god i hope they show up at the
moment
you and i
your family
no
no we just got here you go do it
no they're doing the thing like where he
gets blinded he's not dead yeah
but why would they do that twist for
people who don't know that that i'm not
a fan of that i'm not a fan i get it i'm
not a fan we gotta talk about this
welcome back to new rockstars hawkeye's
finale was not what most fans were
expecting and whatever you felt about
this episode we are still left with the
question of what exactly happened to
kingpin what exactly happened to this
show and what the hawk or we really
should say what the owl because you know
why did they just make it a hawk you
know are owls any more native to
manhattan than hawks are maybe that's in
case you find an owl in central park
hawk might be harder to come by
missed opportunity either way and a
terrifying fate for those shrunken
tracksuits i know what owls do to the
prey that they kill it's a brutal
horrible death
their limbs are not going to be where
they used to be eric it's to me one of
the most horrific mcu deaths was frank
in the first ant-man movie it when he
just was shrunk into a little
puddle of goo dude
still haunts me this is right up there
with it i hate when they just leave
shrunken people shrunken and then that's
the end of their lives i i don't like
that
um well anyway this is inside marvel
it's new rockstar's weekly marvel
reaction show this week we are reacting
to the finale of hawkeye and this
episode's getting a lot of mixed
reactions on social media while we tend
to be marvel appreciators here at new
rockstars it's really because marvel
just gives us a lot to appreciate and i
think there was a lot to appreciate in
this episode but i think it's fair to
say compared to the previous five
episodes it did at times feel like it
was an episode of a different series we
have some thoughts as to why that might
be the case whether you had a lot of
questions coming out of this finale or
if your only question is why did people
like this as much as i did don't worry
we're gonna be here with answers we're
gonna work through it together oh by the
way i'm eric voss and i am so glad to be
here to talk this through with mt what's
going on buddy dude this episode was it
was fun it was kind of you know
kind of crazy here and there but like i
had an overall good time you know it's
good to see you know grills and the crew
helping out in the any way they can
yeah they had an uh a bigger role than i
thought they would have in this finale
for sure uh lots of surprises um both
good and both just kind of confusing
ones but let's break down what happened
this episode it started strong with
eleanor meeting kingpin vincent
d'onofrio in the flesh returning with
that voice and his cane and his cuff
links from the netflix daredevil series
we learned that eleanor had been working
off the debt that was owed by her
husband derek bishop and now she wants
out of it uh but kingpin's like ah
you're still bringing in quite a bit of
money through private security yes and
we learned that she had killed armand
and framed jack but we never actually
see that we never really got to see
eleanor bishop's sword work in the show
but i wanted to see her murder someone
so i can hate her more
yeah it's it's kind of hard to i was
hoping that would be a big reveal after
the earlier episodes like right little
uh hints at her nimble yeah i thought we
were gonna see like a showdown between
her and kate like that's what i wanted
the entire season if you never got it
and i would say even kingpin in this
moment wanted it he was twitching he was
ready to explode he's like
let's stop talking and he flips over the
desk and he just and they both yeah
that'd be nice that'd be a great way to
start the episode oh man give us the
seventh episode i want to see what this
series was supposed to have done in the
final episode um but uh kate reacts to
this footage uh footage that by the way
mt was somehow previously set up to
record by elena in the corner of this
room and then was recovered by elena the
same morning and elena knew what room to
say this is very good man in this weird
tiki bar office that was at the top of
his tower what was this location in room
i don't know uh but clint finally calls
kate his partner so we're we're ready to
go um and then maya meets kingpin who
made sure to change into hawaiian shirt
under his white suit jacket now isn't
this casual yeah right he's just he's
looked around he's like why am i why am
i wearing something that needs cufflinks
why don't i just keep the hawaiian shirt
short sleeve under the jacket and people
won't know the difference and i could
save myself having to pick out which
cufflinks i need to wear because that
takes me a good 90 minutes exactly just
he's playing efficient
playing smart during this conversation
maya claims to have dropped her pursuit
of the ronin but kingpin uh knows that
she is lying and he orders kazzy to kill
her because this city belongs to me
and uh i loved seeing that that come
back from the daredevil show um so clint
and kate home alone together a bunch of
trick arrows and then they get the
larper staffed as caterers at the bishop
company holiday party and uh kazzy waits
about 30 seconds before beginning to
spray 30 rock with bullets but don't
worry it takes a full 30 minutes before
the tourists out front of the building
to notice that this is happening um but
kate duels the elena while clint fights
cazzy there's some really great uh
action going on here i i really love the
lateral shot of kate and elena just like
fighting through the office space oh my
god it's so cool and then uh clint
during his escape he gets stuck in the
the 30 rock christmas tree he meets an
owl uh and then kate timbers this whole
tree uh one of my favorite moments of
the episode weird uh decision by kate
but i respect it because it was a really
cool scene
it looks great uh and then they just
unload these trick arrows on the
tracksuits including a pim arrow that
this time shrinks stuff it shrinks it he
trusts a bro truck which gets
immediately snatched by an owl and
i'm sorry can we just talk about this
for a second because owls are birds of
prey that owl grabbed that truck because
it heard and probably spotted the little
shrunken human beings inside and it's
gonna claw them out of it
and they use their talons to crush their
rats or rodents or whatever squirrels
they're hunting at night time and it
suffocates them to death and then
devours them and imagine being one of
those shrunken russian mafia members i
know they were trying to ram into people
they're awful people that you could you
know they probably deserved their death
i don't think anyone deserves a death
that horrific that's awful
giant owl beak eating you or maybe
feeding you to its children that is a
nightmare hey man that's why you don't
do crime
there's always a risk of that happening
when you do crime that's what i hear
that messed me up honestly that took me
out of the episode i think that
that's that's like
listen marvel alex like i can excuse you
blowing up the hulk
it really is gruesome fashion but not
this
i absolutely can this just this
triggered me this freaked me out um
well clint and elena fight on the ice
and clint is able to change elaina's
mind by doing that good old whistle that
we've uh that's been a huge part of mcu
uh of mcu lore for the past six months
clint completed the black widow sister
whistle um but you know it leads to this
really really beautiful moment of
catharsis between these two grieving
mercenaries uh i think it's great that
uh you know since black widow was denied
a funeral during end game that uh
through this series they've been able to
properly mourn her and move on from her
i would argue that's what the black
widow movie was for i don't think we
needed six episodes that are pretty much
thematically all just about natasha
romanov
and not so much about these other
characters beyond their relationship
with natasha romanov but whatever i was
happy to get that i i just wish that
there was other stuff that was explored
about these characters uh anyway uh
kingpin joins afraid and for a moment
everything is awesome
rips off a car tour and i love that
because before he's known for slamming a
car door in the netflix show now he rips
off a car door
so cool the dude takes an arrow to the
chest just snaps it off he gets rammed
by eleanor's car into a toy story and
then he just throws kate bishop uh into
several different stacks of stuffed
animals um it's it's just really cool to
see how much power he has my dude's a
powerhouse i don't know what happened
but like this dude is juiced up juiced
uh juice is loose in kingpins veins uh
but kate uses that coin flick maneuver
that she you know the one that she
mastered after half a dozen tries to
flick kingpin's cuff link
into that too dangerous arrow that was
basically just a less powerful explosive
than the one that she fired at the truck
in episode three but she cooks kingpin
just a bit but allows him to escape
until he runs into maya who raises a gun
to shoot him but the camera tilts up so
we only hear a gunshot and a thud to the
ground but we do not see a body
king but still alive probably we'll
explain why um but throughout this
episode maya has killed kazzy uh kate
gets eleanor arrested jack goes full
swordsman carries that sword
to
the party he's already
you know how awkward it is to kind of
carry a sword at your sheath at a at a
crowded party you know he's knocking in
the center he's bumping some people with
several people with no sword no doubt
helps them fight the tracksuits so he
ended up being just a good guy but we
never learned uh really where he goes
after this or why he was so stupid in
this show we'll talk about him too uh
but then kate joins clint with the pizza
dog who is now named lucky as he is in
the comics
uh but we saw uh this dog benefit from
zero recent luck at any point since kate
brainstormed pizza related names for him
i don't know why she suddenly decided to
call him lucky and didn't say this
earlier but hey good thing we delayed
that to an off-screen adr line in the
final scene
glad we got that in uh and then on the
barton farm and christmas is where we
leave ourselves where we learn that the
avengers watch was engraved with the
shield logo and the number 19. referring
to shield agent 19 aka mockingbird which
is normally bobby morris's designation
but apparently it is now laura barton's
confirming uh one thing that we were
wondering about her character but it
seems like having no other significance
than just having that i don't know why
laura barton would be so nervous about
this shield logo and the number 19 being
on there why
is there something else on this watch
doesn't seem like it
but if the world were to see the shield
logo with the number 19 on it the barton
life on the farm in missouri would be
over as they know like there's 18 more
watches
[Laughter]
wait 19. i mean to be fair empty of you
and i got that we'd probably be like
travissory and then we ruin their lives
but then we get this post-credits scene
uh and they show us the full four minute
i can do this all day
performance from rogerson musical so fun
so fun i'm glad that they did those guys
are so talented i was like oh my god
they went all in for just like a little
like segment at the beginning of the
first episode they went all in so like
respect to them yeah i love it and the
the lyrics the music the choreography
the performances everything about this
is just so well produced and i love it i
still want to see the full two-act
musical release it on disney blessed
release it take it on tour i want to see
your friend nico de jesus and i want to
see him do his little dance it was
awesome he is so talented everyone adam
pascal incredible now we've been having
some fun i've been you know poking i've
been doing like a stupid cinema since
thing at this show i get it there's
still a lot to appreciate from the show
don't worry i'm gonna break it down
we're gonna talk about it but however
you felt about this finale we're here
with you we're gonna process it together
we're going to get to the bottom of
whether or not kingpin is alive or dead
he's alive don't worry
the hawkeye inspired latest obsession
shirt over at new rockstarsmerch.com is
about to disappear so go grab one quick
but they also have a brand new kingpin
shirt long live the king and long live
that king please there's also a really
fun tracksuit mafia trust a bro moving
company shirt there's also just an
incredible lineup of spider-man no way
home designs that you gotta check out
like our strange entanglement shirt i
think that's my favorite shirt we've
made all year new rockstars merch so
yeah jump on that and when you get a
latest obsession shirt you'll get the
outed option to leave a message that
will show up at the bottom of inside
marvel episodes like we got jesse who
says yo bro will santa fisk bring us
chaos in the multiverse
i uh
we just have to hope that he brings us
chaos in the mcu at least before
he they start bringing them i would love
to see
variants just running amok in the mcu
just trying to like fight each other for
for like land in new york that'd be
great
[Laughter]
this city belongs to me no this city
belongs to me no this city belongs to me
me me me
then ryan says so i'm kind of nervous to
ask this but did grylls survive episode
six yes it looked like he did he did
he's like naming them grills makes me
kind of like bring the bags despite they
could have named him anything they named
him the guy in the comics who dies uh
but he did survive the last we saw him
he was talking to other police officers
he's a firefighter yes so you're talking
to the other first responders saying no
no we're the good guys we're we're
practically avengers just a fun little
moment but it looks like he's safe he's
alive zach waters says do you think ned
will become a hobgoblin in a future
spider-man movie um we are not going to
spoil spider-man no way home in this
episode of inside marvel just because we
know we have some hawkeye fans who are
watching hawkeye but have not seen um
spiderman no way home yet um but we uh i
don't think it's too much of a spoiler
to say that there are some
weird wizard things going on with ned in
spiderman no way home mt made an amazing
video about that that went on the
channel yesterday um so i think it's
more likely that he is a sorcerer and as
a future as a sorcerer and or wizard
it's hard to know how though because he
is a sony property so i don't think he's
going to show up on a disney plus show
his future seems limited to whatever
spider-man stuff they want to develop in
the future but hey make a a sorcerer ned
and mj show where he's a wizard at mit
she's a scientist at mit
and they just have to deal with the
madness that i mean i would watch that
show i love those characters i would
love it i really hope that we see them
in iron heart like because iron heart
takes place yeah it would just yeah it'd
have to be another like
sony joint production with marvel or
marvel would have to like buy those
characters from sony to put them in
ironheart uh yeah i think it's it's hard
to have just those sony characters
because anytime ned uh showed up in uh
infinity war and an in-game that was a
package deal with getting peter parker
in there from sony um all right let's
let's talk about the big question this
episode mt right eric uh what the hawk
happened to kingpin at the end of this
cause like it seems like he got shot but
i think we know it does seem like he got
shot
yeah we did hear the gun shot we heard
the heavy thud something hit in the
ground immediately after however the
episode uses that classic tv trope of
just deliberately not showing the moment
of the death and the rule is no corpse
no death
i mean we've seen this so many times
we've seen it in like walking dead and
game of thrones and lost we saw it
recently in squid game this is just
something that tv shows do where if you
don't see the person drop dead bleed out
the life go out of their eyes
they love to leave that door open so
they can bring them back in some way for
sure now it could be that disney plus
just didn't want to show a gruesome shot
to the head i don't think that's the
case there because this whole gun to the
face moment is a direct pull from the
comics when daredevil exposes kingpins
lies to echo similar to the way clint
exposed kingpin's lies to echo uh last
episode of hawkeye so ekko shoots
kingpin in the face but he is able to
survive this he just gets blinded uh and
he does suffer a major career setback
it's a very big deal for him but then
later on in the comics he gets like
reconstructive eye surgery so it's a big
deal it's something that kingpin goes
through but i think it's more likely now
that we just see kingpin either blind or
with one eye shot out in the echo series
whenever it comes back and they clearly
teased this by having kingpin's last
words before the shot be
our family doesn't always see eye to eye
for the first time ever
[Laughter]
that would be fun
get some goofy movies that would be
great just to get the power up what's
his name powertrain forget his name
powerline powerline that's exactly what
it was yes now it is also possible that
kingpin could have just grabbed that gun
pointed upward they squeeze the trigger
you know and then they both thud to the
ground in a struggle and that christmas
music takes takes over it was off screen
really anything is possible i just think
clearly they're doing the eye moment
like if they are doing anything with
this that would be the only thing the
only rational explanation to why they
did it this way because
kingpin was one of the best parts of the
marvel netflix world
he's super violent his the psychology of
his character's fascinating so to just
like kill him off off screen with my
executing like this depriving fans of
getting to know donafrio's version of
the character really and to bring him
into the series to hype up this big guy
episode after episode and then just kill
him off would just be like a failure of
expectation management by marvel studios
to the highest degree and marvel is not
that dumb they like money you know they
got a plan here um i think it is okay to
just live in this reality in which
kingpin is still alive and we'll talk
about what that means i i just i gotta
say a quick aside setting up this whole
mystery of whether or not he's dead i i
just think that kind of sucks because
it's not a really fun debate to have you
have to know this thing from the comics
when you're watching this to know what
they're doing here and if you're just a
casual fan as most people are who are
watching the show they're going to be
like oh so they just they just killed
them off it was off screen but why would
you do it that way mt are
you've been on twitter is anyone really
enjoying this is he dead or is he a live
debate right now i mean it seems that
you know people are very much divided
about you know about this whole kingpin
death thing and i it makes sense because
like a lot of people really wanted to
see him you know rise up and become this
huge marvel villain and like we know
he's not dead from the comics and like
it's just highly likely that marvel
wants to use this amazing actor vincent
and afria in the future but yeah for
them to do that
um in this episode and not really like
you know tease him surviving in a
post-credits scene it just feels really
yeah really like a really interesting
decision by marvel no i think i think
it's a bad decision by marvel i'm not
afraid to you know afraid of this i
think it was a misstep to do it this way
and i think we needed a post-credits
scene we need some ending thing like how
cool would it be we post credit scene
open back up on vincent d'onofrio
both eyes shot out of his head but
somehow the dude is just able to
rage stand up and scream like how
terrifying would that be two bloody
bullet holes in the guy's head like you
could do the same thing like you did in
that episode of loki it seems to kill
off loki and then post credit scene
opens back up he's still alive marvel
fans know how that works we're fine with
it but now he put us in a situation
where like
we are forced to kind of cling to one of
two realities one we got an episode that
lied to us with the laziest possible tv
trope that
you have to know this one daredevil
comic to have any sense of how kingpin
would survive this or two the mcu is
just a hell of a lot lamer than it was a
week ago and obviously we're sticking
with the first explanation but that's
not a really fun place to be in either i
don't think this was a fun move oh yeah
it definitely wasn't a fun move and a
lot of people are going to be upset but
i could totally see from like a business
standpoint why marvel would have done it
this way because like you know they have
the echo series coming out and like you
know they want to they want people to
watch that show so if they were like in
in trailers or in pro material hey do
you want to know what happened to
kingpin like oh it's in the sango show
um so that's sort of
what i think they're doing on but like
yeah i do agree that like i do not 100
like how it was handled in this episode
um we should have definitely got like
i'm alive jeez um because everyone loves
the kingpin right and i was already on
board with watching echo show that
prologue scene with her as a kid in
class i'm like i will watch four seasons
of this series you know um i don't need
this big twist and like yeah you can
still have kingpin as a threat but just
give us a bit more to show like how use
it as a character building moment for
him as opposed to just like an
off-screen mystery that was like a bad
episode of lost move you know and and
it's not the kind of move that this show
has normally made something was going on
behind the scenes of the show maybe
they've reduced the episode count last
minute maybe they're like oh we are
going to work in kingpin this is going
to come out at the same time as
spider-man no way home and the hawkeye
team is like well we had a different
thing in mind for how this is going to
dovetail together and they're like no no
you have to reshoot this reshoot because
it felt like most of the scenes were
re-shot this episode there was a rush
dialogue there was 80 it's like what we
saw in the falcon in the winter soldier
it felt like they found this episode in
the edit and it does not seem like it
was intended to be it was not scripted
this way initially because the same team
who wrote all these other episodes that
were so good there's no way they write
an episode that is this rushed and i
know a lot of people are defending it
saying oh i still loved it is there
something wrong with me there's nothing
wrong with you but you may just be
someone who also likes cw shows that are
also poorly written and you're willing
to let that still entertain you which
good for you i wish i could live in your
world because i i feel like i would be a
happier person but like we appreciate
good creative decision making and marvel
normally does that so we have to be
honest when they don't hit the mark and
they did not hit the mark in this finale
yeah no i i think that this finale you
know for me anyway i think that there
was a lot of good things that there was
a lot of it was really fun like i really
liked the trick arrow stuff i love
the tree following the owl action even
though it is kind of creepy um i i
really love how you know jack he just
ended up being just a weirdo that loves
swords i i love that about his character
and though we didn't really know about
his character at all which is kind of
sucky you know i do love that we're
being introduced to this really lovable
type character but yeah i do think that
this episode wasn't the strongest so
it's probably one of the weakest
episodes of the season and the editing
was just really choppy and i do think
that they're they're i have this weird
feeling that like you said
there might have been another villain
here because like but one of the biggest
upsets for me about this whole series
was kazi because kazi in the comics is
the clown and he was supposed to be this
i thought he was gonna be this huge
character in this huge um opposition for
for clint barton but he just ended up
being this guy that
sort of was dating uh echo and then now
he's he might be dead i don't know it's
just some yeah character which is kind
of a bummer they gave him this like um
random rant that was in the final
episode this was supposed to be mine but
they clearly cut a scene from the
episode 4 intro where that kid was
supposed to be young cazzy in the karate
academy
but they didn't give him any lines he
just gets like beaten in one of the
earlier sparring rounds and like we
didn't get any sense that he had any
kind of career envy until he said this
was supposed to be mine like
they they completely reduced that
character i don't know what that
character feels like
might have been lost in the edit or
something i don't know it just feels
weird and i'd say that this is something
that drives me crazy about these disney
plus shows which i have to say disney
plus overall as a rollout has been
one for the books it's been incredible
like the programming they've had
in the in 2021 um but they keep doing
this thing where they release these like
hour-long episodes that actually have
like 38 minutes of real content in it
you know and like use your run time like
i unders if you shoot it like why do you
edit it out like just put it all in
there because what you produced was not
a coherent 38 minutes of story
it was all over the place tonally it
didn't make sense so i don't know why
the notes are being applied the way they
are i think the creatives feel hamstrung
to not overlap with some of the other
things marvel might have in development
and they're they're told oh actually you
have to cut this from the episode or
actually don't these shows feel
very produced at the end of the day
uh which isn't a bad thing generally if
everyone's on the same page but if
people aren't on the same page like loki
wanna vision they seem very much on the
same page with those show runners falco
winter soldier hawkeye seem to be on
very different pages with the
showrunners but i wanted to talk about
this uh kingpin's future because this
dude is an absolute unit he took an
arrow to the chest he snapped it off the
guy super powered obviously and they
really they did dial that up a bit more
in on disney plus how do you think the
mcu is going to justify all that beef
are we talking super soldier serum are
we talking it's just all muscle under
there and he
was just trained a lot the guy doesn't
skip any day i mean i think that it has
to has something to do with the super
soldier serum because we see um agent 19
introduced in this episode who is
mockingbird and we know that agent 13
who is used to be uh you know sharon
carter well she is still is a sharon
carter um yeah you know she's going to
be introduced as a power broker so i
think that there is some type of
relationship between kingpin and the
power broker that we will see in these
street level marvel shows uh moving
forward so yeah it feels like an armored
wars subplot oh sure but i want to ask
umt what does kingpin's role in the show
tell us about the way daredevil will fit
in the mcu
based off of kevin feige's confirmation
before no way home that charlie cox
would be playing daredevil in the mcu i
mean i think that you know daredevil is
going to be trying to dismantle this
empire obviously that kingpin has built
and i'm one of my biggest questions from
the series is whether or not daredevil
and king kim ping have actually met in
this universe because it doesn't seem
like they've met or else daredevil would
have shown up i feel like daredevil
should have been here for all of this
action right this was happening in new
york in like a really hot spot so like
no daredevil yeah it's kind of weird
yeah this is a different version of
kingpin than we saw in the in the
netflix show this version of kingpin
didn't have amaya lopez that he cared so
much about you know he didn't have a
tracksuit mafia those things would have
come up in the netflix world
if if it was so connected so i think we
are looking at a variant version of the
character and i think that also tells us
that uh daredevil in the future of the
mcu it's just going to be like a bit of
a variant i and i think people are like
oh but we like so much about what they
did on those uh netflix daredevil shows
i mean yeah there was a lot of great
stuff but i think you can kind of pick
and choose a la carte which of that
backstory you want to canonize as mcu
canon by just having him reference it in
dialogue and then for everything else
just kind of leave it open ended i think
that's probably what feige's going to do
yeah i i don't think frankie really has
much of a choice i'm
get i'm guessing with the whole netflix
contracts and all that stuff they
probably would just want to get their
events all right this is our universe
you can't use any of our events go think
of your own stuff and i don't think he
has a problem doing that that's honestly
his preferred choice to be able to like
tell a new history and not be held to
what the history was before and i think
the answer is going to be that these are
variants as opposed to this guy was in
new york at the same time doing all of
his stuff in daredevil season one
hanging out with the hand in season two
all that stuff no there's gonna be like
a different hand there's gonna be kind
of a different story there um and i i
think it's gonna be better ultimately
yeah i think we might see like an
implied netflix character crossover in a
secret wars event or something just be
like oh yeah i'm the kingpin that you
know and love right on the dirt i've let
you know yes briefly um but yeah for the
most part with all these characters that
we're seeing in these disney plush shows
are just completely new all right we're
going to talk more about this episode
but first something that could be just
as big and scary as kingpin is credit
card debt upstart can help lift that
burden and help you avoid the big bad of
debt upstart is a fast and easy way to
pay off your debt with a personal loan
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or finding personal expenses over
half a million people have used upstart
to get a simple fixed monthly payment
unlike other lenders upstart looks at
more than just your credit score like
your income and your employment history
this means they can offer some smarter
rates with trusted partners with a 5
minute online rate check you can see
your rate up front for loans between one
thousand and fifty thousand dollars you
can receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
and find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com marvel that's upstart.com
marvel don't forget to use our url to
let them know that we sent you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com marvel we
also want to thank bluetooth for
sponsoring this episode guys there's
nothing sexier than confidence and
bluetooth can help give you that
confidence where it counts bluetooth is
a unique online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis but in chewable tablets and
at a fraction of the cost you can take
them anytime day or night so you can
plan ahead or be ready for whenever an
opportunity arises the process is simple
sign up at bluetooth.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you will
receive your prescription within days
and the best part it's all done online
so no visits to the doctor's office no
awkward conversations and no waiting in
line at the pharmacy bluetooth tablets
are made in the usa and prepared and
shipped direct to your door in a
discrete package so if you could benefit
from some extra confidence when it's
time to perform blue chew can help you
and we've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free when you
use our promo code inside marvel at
checkout just pay the five dollars in
shipping that's bluechew.com promo code
inside marvel to receive your first
month free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
we thank bluetooth for sponsoring this
episode and we want to thank helix for
sponsoring this episode you might lose
sleep because you're staying up late
watching the latest hawkeye episode but
you shouldn't lose any sleep because of
a bad mattress helix sleep has a quiz
that matches your body type and your
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you they have soft medium
and firm mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down if you tend to sleep
hot even a helix plus mattress for plus
size sleepers i have a helix mattress i
love it the quiz matched me with a
medium firm mattress with lumbar support
sleeps cool perfect the mattress ships
right to your door for free no need to
go to the mattress store just go to
helixsleep.com inside marvel take their
two minutes sleep quiz and they will
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life they have a 10 year warranty and
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at
helixsleep.com inside marvel and we want
to thank stance for sponsoring us today
we recently got a shipment of some
stance socks and we love them they're
very well made super soft have some
funky and unique designs to them you may
not always be able to see my socks
they're down in no man's land but rest
assured they got some cool batman
designs that's how batman works he's a
creature of the knight you just gotta
trust that he's there watching founded
in 2009 stance apparel represents a
radical reinvention of socks underwear
and active apparel with a sharp focus on
comfort quality and creativity stance
brings an atypical aesthetic alongside
some of pop culture's hottest
collaborators for the ultimate in style
and self-expression because everything
you wear should be a direct extension of
who you are and how you feel one of the
coolest parts of stance socks is the pop
culture collaborations they do they have
socks with designs from dc the office
marvel and pixar right now so i'm gonna
grab some of those boba vet socks ahead
of the book of boba fett starting next
week it's cool to express yourself with
super comfortable super fun socks and
stance believes that the perfect fit
matters more than fitting in that those
who feel good do good go see for
yourself register for an account at
stance.com and get 15 off your first
purchase use promo code marvel at
checkout to apply enjoy the color and
comfort of a life less ordinary with
stance all right buddy our second
question is what the hawk is laura
barton's history as mockingbird and why
was she so eager to keep it a secret and
will we see her again uh great question
yeah so she clearly was the shield agent
right uh agent 19 they're making her
mockingbird i think this is a fun choice
for for linda cartellini's character uh
and i don't know how much of a future
this gives her uh though like i think if
we do see her again it will tie in with
like sharon carter right in armor wars i
just don't i i wonder you know when we
come out of eternals
eternal's really underperformed at the
box office and you can even hear the
marvel executives saying i don't know
how much of this movie we're gonna like
bring back and make sure to follow up on
in the future
like
the truth is that hawkeye has been the
lowest rated show on disney plus that
they've done uh so i don't know if
they're gonna follow up with linda
cardellini as agent 19. i think that was
just kind of a little wink saying oh
there's a reason why she and clint met
uh it wasn't just she was a farm girl in
missouri that they were both uh working
in the world of espionage and i'm fine
with that i'm fine with that i don't
think that necessarily negates the
existence of a bobby morse especially
now that lord barton is retired uh and
there could be easily a new agent 19 in
the same way that i wouldn't be
surprised if there's a new agent 13
because sharon carter is out of the game
or she's in a new game i should say
no i i have this weird feeling that we
could potentially see uh laura barton in
secret invasion because secret invasion
is oh sure huge thing with the squirrels
and like shields was and the scrolls
were involved with shield and all that
stuff so yeah maybe laura there's still
a chance that laura barton could be a
skrull or she has some type of uh
history with of dealing with the scrolls
so i think that this could be very much
a teaser for all right um we were giving
laura barton something to do and you'll
see her very soon in secret wars uh i
mean in secret invention yeah i will see
my hopes for any squirrel sighting were
dashed in this show uh which i know that
was a big reach to expect this one watch
to have the whole database of where
every scroll is on the planet i was just
hoping at some point maybe one of those
track suits could have been revealed as
a scroll or something like that but no
we didn't get anything let's let's ask
what the hawk is next for elena biloba
are we ever gonna learn more about val's
involvement with eleanor and with
kingpin you think uh i would hope so
because we didn't get any of those
answers in this co in this series i
really wanted to see val um at some
point in this episode and we never did
which is a bummer because i want to see
val and kingpin interact because they're
amazing actors um but that would have
been fun but in regards to elena i think
that she's just going to have to be you
know deal with the fact that her sister
sacrificed herself and she's going to
maybe get inspired by her sacrifice
because you know up until this point
she's been a very
you know self-serving person and so
hearing that her
her sister
basically risked it all for humanity
might inspire her to take up her mantle
so we might see the beginnings of her
you know becoming black widow because of
this news but what do you think is next
for elena um i think whatever dark
avengers or thunderbolts plan that is in
the works with val with with john walker
potentially with abomination i think
that's all still in the works um i'm
just wondering why elena doesn't
question val using her as a weapon i
think that was
an important lesson that was discussed
on this show but it didn't seem like
elena truly learned it it seemed like
the only point of that final
conversation was to properly grieve
natasha but like
clint was being exploited as a weapon in
his past elena is currently being used
by basically a new drakov and i want
elena
to face that maybe there's i just want
her to acknowledge that val is a bad
actor who is
trying to use her for for nefarious
reasons
and the fact that she just so
unquestioningly
took that assignment uh and like it
needed clint to
whistle and to say this whole speech
about natasha for her to realize that he
wasn't worth killing uh it's like she
learned nothing from the events of black
widow um which the whole point of these
things is to force us to care about
watching these other things and with
each whenever when they do it poorly
it's just like doing wrong i love that
scene between her and clint on the ice i
thought it was a beautiful conversation
uh it's just why bring uh
elena in this show if she isn't gonna
have any identity of her own other than
black widow i think my favorite moment
for her was when she dusted and undusted
and it was so fascinating to be like i
lost five years of my life and then she
just goes where's natasha and it
honestly feels like what they did in
last jedi with finn and they just made
him say where's rey and then his
character
no longer has any of his own importance
in the story he's just there as a foil
for someone else so that's obviously not
gonna be the case with florence pugh
she's great she has a ton of agency in
the way she's playing this character
obviously they have a future in mind for
her uh but that future gave us uh no
evidence in these six episodes but empty
let's let's go into some final thoughts
on this series i feel like i've been
negative on this show but overall these
six episodes have been uh pretty fun i
think
a lot of standout moments throughout
each episode the car chase in episode
three uh everything we learned about uh
maya lopez the introduction of kingpin
this show had some great chemistry
between clint barton and uh and kate
bishop haley steinfeld was a find for
this show she was incredible in the way
she played this character um really
really great casting um and uh yeah it
was just a fun christmas show and i
think my favorite thing about this
finale is just how much it seems to
reference christmas movies in little
ways and i think that's gonna be my
favorite thing to look at in the
breakdown is like oh they tried to make
the ultimate christmas uh story between
die hard and home alone and home alone 2
specifically there's just like a lot of
little things that they did that i
really really did appreciate and i love
the christmas music especially episode 5
the way they brought in the stings of
your mean one mr grinch the the charlie
brown christmas music when clint's
walking by himself they just did a
really really great job of that
obviously roger's musical i can do this
all day i can watch that all day
i'm super grateful for this series for
it really did feel like a stocking uh
full of great goodies there's just one
little lump of coal at the bottom but
overall i can handle that coal and we
need that coal to stay warm especially
for in west virginia
no i completely agree like this this
show it was really great and as a person
who really loved the matt fraction
hawkeye comics this felt like a really
great adaptation of those comics it
literally felt like those comics brought
to the screen and you could tell that
matt fraction was very much involved
with this episode with this whole series
because
that humor is there matt fraction is an
insanely funny dude and so my my biggest
like fear or my biggest um like worry or
want for the show i should say was like
i wanted it to be funny and i wanted um
kate and clint to have really good
chemistry and they really did in this
episode haley steinbeck brought it
jeremy renner was great and um you know
this show very much felt like the matt
fraction comics so like that's why i
really love this show and this show had
honestly had no business being as good
as it was um considering that a lot of
people you know hawkeye it's hawkeye now
she's like the least
um i don't know respected avenger and
like they make a lot of the jokes a lot
of those jokes in the marvel comics so
i'm not being mean he's like the people
the avengers people are the least hyped
for so the fact that this show was this
good is pretty amazing and i think that
the show was a overall a positive and a
good move on marvel studios and i really
want to season two i think so i think so
i agree with you i think it's really
really hard to end a series right into
that's always the hardest part of
anything to write in a way especially
week after week after fans get
attachments to characters into subplots
that you didn't expect them to get
attachments to so to resolve all that in
a final episode it's it's rare it's it's
not common that they're able to pull it
off that successfully i mean one
division for as great as the show as
that was that final episode had plenty
of weird kind of moves especially with
you know evan peters character that
don't really make any sense um so i
think over time as we look back on the
show we're gonna remember some of the
more fun uh the action every chase scene
every fight scene the
big ass arrow on the bridge ring out of
those arrows the giant arrow on the
bridge um yeah i i um
i'm super grateful for this show and i'm
thankful to everyone for letting me pick
it apart every week with you empty and
and to uh and to break it down and to be
critical of it and know that i still
love all these characters and i and i'm
grateful to these creators for for
giving this to us um grateful we we pay
them eight bucks a month so yeah
but
they better get their money content
jesus christ they're getting our money
they're getting more money from us
now more than ever and increasingly even
more so
in general you know christmas time i try
to have an attitude of an appreciation
we don't have to have a live action of
marvel disney plush shows but we get
them almost every week and we will
continue to get them once every week in
the new year because while that is it
for this episode of inside marvel and
tomorrow of course will be my breakdown
of all the easter eggs i'm also gonna
try to squeeze in a breakdown of this
multiverse of madness trailer that's now
on youtube but um we're going to take
just a like a week break from marvel
content after that until the new year so
next week we're going to release a few
videos on the book of boba fett uh which
we're super excited about tommy's going
back to wikileaks it's going to be wild
because we only we learned that we've
only seen the first half of the first
episode in trailer content robert
rodriguez is hiding uh big reveals that
we're gonna see in the first episode and
beyond so um that's what we're gonna do
the final week of the year and then the
first week of january we're gonna be
back with our regular schedule of all
the new weekly episodes of inside marvel
even when there is a new marvel disney
plush show to talk about and when
there's just marvel news mt and i are
gonna be with you every week and we're
getting a lot more of everything here at
new rock stars so uh just don't worry if
you don't see as many like spider-man
videos next week we're just taking some
holiday time but mt i want to thank you
for closing out 2021 with us here on
inside marvel because doing the show
with you every week reacting episodes as
they come out on disney plus whatever
the big marvel news is it's just been a
true delight you've been such an amazing
contribution to our team this year and
i'm so grateful for you you guys have
completely changed my entire year like i
started this year off completely
different and so to be able to do this
with you guys every day
is a honestly a dream come true it does
not feel like work for a single second
like this is literally i'm living the
dream and i'm doing it with you buddy so
this is great yeah well we're so glad to
have you with us and for everyone
watching don't forget to check out our
many great merch options in
rockstarsmerch.com that long live the
king shirt the bro shirt all this great
stuff and our strange entanglement shirt
is a great one follow me at eavos follow
mt mastertainment follow new rockstars
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcast thank you for watching
and we'll close with our uh
maybe our favorite moment but if not
just at least a randomly hilarious
moment this episode take a look do you
remember when you peed in your pants in
the hamptons
i do
everybody does
you